adam you haven't you have a new you have
a new baby i have a new kid
congratulations are in order for
leighton meester and adam brody
the couple has welcomed their second
child together and
it's a boy the former oc actor confirmed
the happy news thursday
on twitch's the fun time boys game night
spectacular
adam you have it you have a new you have
a new baby i have a new kid i have a boy
he's a dream he's a dream boy adam and
leighton have been married since 2014.
and are already proud parents to
four-year-old daughter arlo
of course both are known for playing
television icons
who can forget leighton as gossip girl's
famous upper east side socialite blair
waldorf
and adams starred in the oc as the
eccentric and lovable
seth cohen in 2017 the duo admitted
they've shared a laugh
about their characters ending up
together in real life
once a occasionally once a year we have
a seth and blair day yeah
we're gonna dress up and uh i don't know
it doesn't excite us i think because
we're just human beings and
i don't know but i mean it's exciting
for a laugh
it's good for a laugh the following year
leighton had
this to say about her real-life
relationship with adam
i think we're a pretty modern couple i
think we sort of
toggle back and forth we both sort of we
both work but also being actors like i
think we
understand what each other we're both
going through
plus the actress tells et that one perk
of working in the biz
is that it allows them to have some much
needed family time
i also think the nice thing about being
an actor is that you can
work a lot and when work is work it's
like it's super intense and long hours
and you might not see
your family for a long period but then
you know i'll have like months off at a
time so i can really like be home and
spend time so
i prefer it that way the actress
currently stars on the abc
series single parents and adam has
popped up as a guest star
he hilariously plays leighton's
characters loser x
and baby daddy great on the way there i
can show you this amazing place where
you can get gas
it's a gas station i have to get gas on
the show
he is such a little dummy and it's it's
it's very cute
and he's very handsome and in real life
that's 98 not true he's mostly
totally like a grown-up the actress
recently opened up to e.t
about working alongside her hubby he is
the baby daddy
in real life in real life exactly um
it's great it's so great sometimes i'll
be like oh yeah i forgot i'm married to
you like i'll just like turn a corner
and he's standing there
um but it's great it's really nice with
him here he's very much part of the
family